for sure bienvenue out GameSpot's as Jim
Appel Danielle O'Dwyer uh that's that's
my French i'm done but i'm here with the
guys from Mother Russia bleeds Jonathan
devolver is here I've got Fred and slow
you guys have come all the way from
Paris yeah show us this game John you're
the window dressing helping us with
translation if we're quiet as a French
emergency i'll jump in yeah no problem
at desa lame-o more français a
traitorous ok no problem it's ok no
problem and mother russia bleeds and
tell us about it it's a bit ly mepham
it's like old-school busy map or we are
working on it since when he on and off
we have an alpha d'shannon we are four
people walking on the team and we wanted
to make something like a street of
region yes it was a main entrance double
dragon rogan renegade oh and we want him
to make him do something very intense
because we like you know the old
building of a very brutal yes and we
like dark things we like like that it
does the dog thing and it was
intentional and we play the Attorney
Anita ism I think one year ago all laid
before and we discovered that it was
sooo possible to make a real good deal
just with a little Tim yeah little team
would sort of great graphics like as in
this game and great music as well which
are slow made and let's get into it
let's start them and have a look because
it's one of those games that you need to
sort of see to appreciate so and what's
happening here who you who you picking
so we are we are showing as the forced
labor we have a egg laid on and it shows
one of the poor characters on the it's
you know the stone deaf character with a
stone the other properties is it will so
enter in the club because it's a
a guy from sorry the story takes place
in the u.s. Society just a narrative
vision okay what's a sound and we we
have some characters who come from the
ready poor poor community yeah in Russia
and yes USSR I'm sorry and this the just
survive they gain money by fighting and
in another side Jerry's the Mafia the
matter with creating a dragon re in
order to make money and one day they
will kidnap poor people you know people
Warners with some never no one knows
them so they are snapped and with slaves
or they disappear yes it is no quiero
and the the materia makes some tests to
create a dragon and the player will
begin to gain by by escaping the ladder
where they've been there have been like
caballo yes experimenting external
Authority actually it looks a streets of
rage Double Dragon great games not very
difficult and some of them they get
difficult and this looks more difficult
this looks like hardcore game yeah
tahrir fellow it was our intention we
don't see the this game is very
challenging you you know and it's
intense it's brutal so if it's so it's a
casual you know it won't be a good thing
for us yeah we want it very difficult
and it's interesting you've a
four-person team yes forth and have it
must take a lot of time to draw all of
the assets for the solitude of course
every you know every variable character
I've I think about 40 animations is each
animations the lot of friends
and it's a lot of a lot of work and
right now just we are Jerry's sorry oh
oh you can rewind as well no no no oh
right now it took drugs oh I have to
expect you there is no lives in this
it's a like you know daiya daiya new
trial you know you have just a live
bhajan and when you lose some summits
and elf do you have the servants
arranged as you the opportunity to make
two things we choose between healthy did
you use a [ __ ] and you inject you some
liquid to get f by f and the other
possibility is to get some desert okay
and when you are on the browser you are
very very fast powerful and you can make
your special moves oh my god the only
way to refill the syringe it's too when
some the NPCs are dying here they are
making 12 agenda jump they are vomiting
on themself yeah and you have to to like
it you will do that so that like that
like that exactly and you fill it back
up again yes you you a picture with your
syringe and you will get more fluid to
to continue the adventure because you
have to to manage your elf yeah so yeah
so one life for each level yes but there
are checkpoints of caruso well we plan
to make eight levels touch finish and so
you can pick a different character for
the different levels as well is there
can you play with two people yes it's
playable for poor people [ __ ] yes oh
wow the people can join in during the
game right now it's local but we plan to
make it online if we have the time and
the z energy because it's a lot of her a
lot of work were little children and the
cartel is that the name of your team
look at Ellie yes it's a society our
society from friends and we are working
with developer and that's rare cool is
that your first game working honor was
the team yes it's a offers game before I
used to work for Ubisoft oh cool just
dance and I yeah Ubisoft wouldn't let
you make a game like this I don't think
so this doesn't have little rabbits
laughing at each other yeah and so does
it get more difficult is it more
difficult to one person if four people
are involved does the difficulty scale
yes the difficulty scale it's you know
it's quite simple it's more NPCs when
you are it's a it's not a real technical
brawler it's a really intense bra it's a
brutal and when when you play a tumult
appear you can do some combos it's
possible I see there's a nice big penis
in the back left as well yes it's a club
very well crud yeah although have you
been to Russia yes I've been to Russia
but I was I was very young and no it's a
it's what I said its alternative vision
approach it oh yeah fair enough and they
said watch which bad guys are they exist
a mafia guys you're talking right now we
are in a club which owned by a bus of
mafia and it's just the guys from the
issue you know it's a it's an El Paso so
guys we saw it down oh yeah jams from
jail it's a npc we used from another
level we will just make a new you
season yes right now it's all going
wrong now I have to explain yeah right
now we are in the crisis because of the
characters a little bit addict and they
have like a little alyssa nations around
when that in this case we just are in
alliston itional found it very well yeah
we like we're friends does this happen
at certain stages in the game we just
freaked out it's a scripted cool all
unscripted so no no it's scripted okay
litter in the story I'm so sorry
excellent yeah so the you guys obviously
working with the vulvar as well big fans
of hotline miami i assume yes we we
loved the game from developers and
liberals the developers yes we love that
game and it's a great it's awesome to be
there right now and to work with
developers ray awesome it's fantastic
and it's great to have you guys here as
well coming to e3 to show off show off
the game especially as there are so many
such a crazy amount of different types
of games at e3 yes here like modern game
development is fascinating yeah and we
are working on on the flats you know and
we are a little bit alone so when we
came here it's so so huge it's a very
impressive itself yeah it's like son
leave the small room into a massive
ruling and the Wow excellent fredericka
slow as well thank you so much for
coming on and thanks as well we didn't
meet you apparently I'm just happy
you're here because the shirt is
fantastic this is like this is real Los
Angeles we do what we can yeah I'm just
I'm just wearing this thing it's
probably i was wearing plaid all week
but this I like my chun-li shared a lot
and when is it available when will we be
able to play mother it will be available
on the baby may be on the up rail or
march cool hope the next year excellent
fingers crossed yes awesome thank you so
much for coming still a pleasure I
really appreciate you very much and
thank you for watching and stay tuned we
got more great games coming up here on
the game spot show right here at e3 it's
day 3 stay tuned